valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france a lancé l'idée de
repousser le début des cours des lycéens
d'une heure qu une mesure qui divise
c'est bfm tv qui en dit plus repousser
la sonnerie d'une heure une idée qui
satisfait le syndicat de lycéens une
aile mais ça ne suffit pas a dit son
président louis boyard c'est pas parce
que l'on commence les cours à 9 heures
que les journées vont être déchargée en
fait on va commencer à 9 heures et finir
à 19 heures disney qui a bien conscience
que l'idée de gagner une heure de
sommeil va faire sourire de toute façon
à chaque fois on va se moquer des
lycéens par s'ils sont jeunes et que le
jeune il veut juste ne pas travailler
non c'est vrai que c'est un véritable
enjeu de santé idée reprise par claire
leconte professeur en psychologie de
l'enfant pendant pour le coup de ne pas
voir leur sommeil en plus que du doigt
moque de nous celui qui nous permet de
bien apprendre notre accord également
leur permettront de se prendre au mot
mais la mesure ne suffit pas dit la
spécialiste il faut aussi organiser une
véritable éducation au sommeil pour que
nos ados se sentent véritablement mieux
alors mal et les prêtres pécresse a
proposé l'expérimentation pour les
lycéens d'île de france ils seraient 500
milles concerné je vois emilie qui mais
non vraiment n'a pas l'air content tu
diffuses et moi le petit jeune à dans le
magnéto est dit on va se moquer des
lycéens parce qu'ils sont jeunes
non on va se moquer des lycéens parce
que c'est ridicule cette proposition
pourquoi vous la trouvez ridicule avait
déjà parce qu'on est peut être un
phénomène à un problème de santé
publique 1 maintenant on est tous passé
par le lycée on sait tous levés super
tôt on en a tous
on a tous galéré au président vous avez
galéré pour tout le monde galère désolé
mais dans ce cas là il faut décaler
toute la société de 1h parce que oui
effectivement moi aussi j'aimerais bien
dormir une heure de plus au goût
commencera une heure plus tard et il y
aura pas de souci ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les études ont prouvé que pour
que les lycéens soient au top du top il
faut qu'ils se couchent avant 22 heures
trouvez moi un seul des gamins qui
disent je ne vais plus tard pour dormir
plus qui se couche à vanves alors donnez
moi mais ils vont vous rétorquer qu'ils
ont des devoirs parce qu'ils sont des
soi-disant des tonnes de devoir est donc
qui termine à 23h minuit à cause des
deux voies on est ou encore une fois on
est tous passés par là et puis 6 écouter
un peu plus en classe ils n'auraient pas
besoin de passer autant de temps sur
leurs devoirs au bal alors
voilà je reste je vous dis pas merci
[Applaudissements]
caroline quel moment à quel moment on se
dit que jason et de vieilles caisses à
savon d'accord avec l anatomie à quel
moment on s'est dit que déjà notre
système est défaillant on est déjà la
risée de l'europe
je vous parle même pas du monde entier à
quel moment on se dit allez on va
rajouter deux trois heures de sommeil
mais ce qu'être on s'en fout on dormira
quand on sera vieux ils sont jeunes ils
vont aux tarnais et c'est comme ça on va
au bout lente ou l'ont trahi
à moins que ce soit un petit buzz que
veuille s'offrir personnellement valérie
pécresse dont on n'entend plus tellement
parlé ces derniers temps les codes
vouloir vivre en santé parce que il me
semble qu'il ya une étude lui même qui
prouve que les notes sont meilleurs pour
les élèves qui travaillent afin qu'ils
se réveillent plus tard ils ont testé à
seattle après la différence c'est que
plutôt que de commencer les cours à 8h45
qu'ils ont commencé à 7h50 ils ont
commencé à 8h45 et c'est vrai que les
notes ont augmenté de 4,5 par an voilà
ils ont testé voilà il commence déjà
vachement plus tôt que nous et ils ont
testé dans différentes villes aux états
unis et toutes les villes on se marche
arrière est survenu à 7 à 7h50 donc
voilà d'accord mais je trouve que vous
êtes résolument arcade toutes les deux
un pardon je vous aurais je suis désolé
mais je pense que c'est au contraire une
excellente mesure pourquoi parce que
c'est une mesure qui est adapté à notre
quotidien
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'à 91 % des
étudiants qui dorment moins de huit
heures par nuit
c'est vraiment des huit heures soit pas
malin car oui oui mais pour combien il
devrait y avoir entre 8 et 10 heures de
sommeil pour gars en forme
le problème on amène à emilie le
problème si tu veux c'est que
aujourd'hui on a tous nos écrans qui
sont face à nous avec cette lumière
bleue qui nous empêche de dormir
donc à un moment donné on va pas pouvoir
se séparer des portables c'est vraiment
une victoire ça mais autant
effectivement et bien faire ensemble
voilà autant tous des cas les talibans
comme s'adapter à la société
on va demander à notre médecin 18 jimmy
est ce que cette mesure
il ya un vrai souci de santé ou est-ce
que d'après vous c'est une mesurette et
cautère sur jambe de bois on va écouter
c'est peut-être intéressant pour les
fumeurs de kate fumeurs de cannabis et
que je diabolo
on est dans les poncifs ok très bien
mais oui non mais excusez moi c'est ce
genre de mesure complètement inutile qui
ne fait pas progresser le niveau des
élèves
c'est le genre de mesure qui coûte rien
du tout et qui permet qu'on parle
effectivement de cette politique on aura
huit ya une mesure extraordinaire
d'autres sociale et deux seuls six
cantons leur entend donc on fait des
contrôles ont fait des contrôles à tout
le monde pour évaluer le niveau mais le
niveau progresse pas les professeurs se
plaignent de perdre du temps à juste
titre lors des corrections ils vont
passer dix jours à 15h à corps et une
copie au lieu de passer ce temps là à
corriger des copies
il devrait peut-être le passé à faire de
l'aide aux devoirs d'une des deux ou
trois heures de soutien scolaire
pourrait vite pour que les élèves
progressent en vo c'est pas le souci
majeur de l'éducation n'est pas sur le
temps de sommeil ils ont qu'à se coucher
plus tôt ils se lèveront plus tôt et ça
ira mieux tous les lycéens qui nous
regardons les étudiants qui vont vous
adorer les lycéens qui veulent se lever
une heure plus tard justement est ce que
vous comprenez vous ne comprenez pas
partager quand même hein je comprends à
49% et je ne comprends pas pour 51%
d'entre en tout cas quand ils commencent
les cours trop tôt sont pas en forme et
lycéens
[Applaudissements]